via un smartphone dont je vous parlais
depuis longtemps je voulais déjà
présenté il ya quelques temps c'est pas
une nouveauté puisque c'est un
smartphone qui est déjà sorti il ya
quelques bonnes semaines mais j'ai pris
le temps avant de pouvoir effectivement
vous en parlez vous dire ce que j'en
pensais je pense que ce smartphone c'est
probablement le meilleur flaccide killer
sous android peut être le meilleur
rapport qualité prix sous android c'est
celui là est ce que vous le reconnaissez
one plus c'est l'adn de one + et
proposer le meilleur des technologies au
meilleur rapport qualité-prix de
proposer des flagships tueur alors il
faut changer quelque chose cette année
ils ont sorti un modèle pro le modèle
pro on l'a eue avec le modèle 7,7 en
début d'année cette proue est là le 7 p
pro du sed pro ossètes et pro il ya une
évolution
il n'essaie pas énorme alors que ce one
plus cette paix pourquoi cette chose de
vraiment pas novateur mais qui continue
elle est loin d'en sont adeptes continue
de proposer des choses vraiment
intéressantes au tarif le plus juste en
tout cas qui me semblent intéressants à
moins de 600 euros
on va faire un tour on va faire le tour
de ce vote +7 théo est ce qu'il tient
vraiment cette promesse est ce que les
one + 71 est vraiment le flagship killer
le smartphone à voir sans drôle quand on
veut le meilleur rapport qualité prix
est-ce qu'il vaut le coup est ce que
wayne plus a fait un bon boulot là
dessus ou pas but
[Musique]
je sais je sais je sais je sais j'en ai
conscience je suis pas attendre et dans
le calendrier pour sortir mon test du
wan plus c'était le plus rapidement
possible ça fait un petit moment ça fait
un petit moment qu'il a été présenté
monsieur dreux est un peu très en retard
là dessus mais vous verriez les
quantités de smartphones qui sort c'est
juste affolant pour moi c'est cool parce
que j'ai plein de travail il ya plein de
produits testés c'est génial il ya plein
de vidéos à faire ménage errements de
smartphones où je suis au record je vous
raconte même page et le au port et nos
deux ça fait un bon moment que je lai
que je teste que j'ai fait plein de
choses avec les récupérer quand j'étais
à new york
mi octobre on est bientôt mi novembre
c'est complètement faux alors je suis
pour que nos enfants un mouton avec ce
one + 7 t c'est vrai quand on l'a reçue
on a vu ce grand cercle la fuite ya ces
différenciant c'est quelque chose de
nouveau il ya une tendance qui se fait
sur les parties caméra un rond comme ça
c'est pas trop mal ce que j'aime bien
surtout c'est ce dégradé de couleurs un
peu plus foncée ici un peu plus pascal
sur le bas j'aime bien alors une fois de
plus votre smartphone vous le protéger
la dé la coque de waele plus et donc
forcément ce pastel disparaît néanmoins
en plus ce sont les fois qu'ils sont
toujours très sympa très calé avec un
joli toucher donc le module photo aux
ressorts et pas grand chose d'autre
c'est pas mal c'est une proposition de
valeur qui et différenciante mais c'est
pas non plus qui va nous transcender de
plus lorsque vous arrivez à l'avant vous
avez un grand écran dans le grand écran
je vous en reparle dans quelques
instants du point de vue retour
d'expérience la partie où je vais un peu
moins accroché c'est sûr ici c'est pas
normal parce que vous avez la gamme cruz
avait le grand écran sans encoches et là
sur le modèle normal et bien vous avez
la petite encoche par contre j'aime
beaucoup le toucher verre dépoli sur
smartphone je trouve ça très doux et
surtout ça ne laisse absolument qu'une
trace de doigt donc si vous utilisez
votre smartphone sans coque de
protection
ça peut arriver et bien pour le coup
vous n'allez pas voir trace douane quand
je vous dis que je préfère les
smartphones sans encoches ça veut pas
dire ça c'est pas beau ça veut juste
dire que si vous avez utilisé comme moi
pendant très longtemps un mois de plus
cette pro sans aucune encoches et bien
lorsque vous avez en retournant coche
tout de suite vous accrocher un petit
peu moins par contre on n'est pas loin
du bord à bord vous avez un menton qui
est quasiment inexistant vous avez de
légers
bord de tous les côtés mais c'est
vraiment minime puisque vous le regardez
comme ça ce qui est vraiment à part ce
smartphone c'est son écran et c'est un
des gros points forts de ce que fait one
plus et notamment avec cette série tu es
un des gros point fort par rapport à la
concurrence de ce one plus cet essai son
écran avec son taux de rafraîchissement
de 90 art alors vous allez me dire
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec un
écran 80 dire qu'est ce que 90 à
varennes mandat porté par rapport aux
écrans 60r que je me trouvais à la
concurrence alors déjà il faut savoir
que l'écran 90 hier c'est pas une
exclusivité de vente plus parce qu'à
d'autres modèles qu'il au fond vous avez
notamment le google pixels 4 vous avez
asus rog phone de monter le même jusqu'à
100 verte avec le réseau fon de mélo en
plus c'était un des rares modèles à
proposer un taux de rafraîchissement 90
à 180 d'hier ça peu importe quoi 90
hertz ce que ça porte ses de la fluidité
lorsque vous allez venir comme ça
navigue et sa porte beaucoup de fluidité
et ce quelque chose que vous n'allez pas
à voir avec un écran 60 hertz
on a un écran fluide amoled une
résolution de 2400 pixels par 1080
instauration vingt neuvième quelque
chose de très allongée et qui marche
très bien lorsque vous la rade et du
contenu multimédia
aujourd'hui beaucoup de vidéos sur
youtube son format 18/9 d'ailleurs j'ai
ça y est la juge de tandt la
désinformation 18 ne viennent pas ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire est
ce que ça vous convient oui ou non
d'ailleurs je suis montant 4 k dites moi
si vous voyez une évolution par rapport
aux vidéos précédentes
voici le préférer le format 18 9e but le
format 16/9 là en tout cas c'est du 29e
alors que le vingt neuvième vous allez
pouvoir regarder effectivement du
contenu 18/9 sans que ce soit trop cros
paix est là si vous mettez du 6/9 sabah
davantage cros paix et tout ça vous
l'avez avec 402 pixels par pouces 6 55
pouces de bonheur un écran qui est très
lumineux hdr 10 plus certifié contre la
lumière bleue donc à l'écran
d'excellente qualité que mon tout cas
j'apprécie beaucoup pour regarder du
contenu multimédia instagram tout ce que
vous voulez des fils des vidéos netflix
tout ce qui vous fait plaisir on a
vraiment un écran de très très très
bonne qualité et c'est en tout cas c'est
une des signatures du bun plus est pour
partie audio est aussi vraiment
excellent pour coter les tunisiens avec
des haut-parleurs stéréo haut parleurs
son côté haut parleurs là ça marche très
très bien
dolby et nos ces compagnies donc pour
les usages multimédias le one depuis cet
été est parfait et merveilleux l'écran
et hop l'autre
on marche bien ça c'est vraiment berio
pousse d'ailleurs vous avez beaucoup de
puissance de la performance qualcomm
snapdragon 855 plus lui giga de ram si
vous êtes gamers et même leur un boost
avec les modes fnatic nous permet
d'aller plus loin de profiter du maximum
de puissance que vous avez derrière donc
vous serez proche n'ont pas déçu pour
faire tourner les jeux du playstation
aucun problème vous avez 128 giga de
stockage en usb 3.0
ça vous permet d'avoir une écriture
lecture qui est beaucoup plus rapide que
de lui fs deux points mais ce qu'ils ne
gâchent pas la fête non plus et la
partie de l'autonomie vous avez batterie
de 3800 milliampères alors on a une
batterie qui est un peu plus petit parce
que vous allez vendre les modèles pro ça
paraît quand même relativement normal le
modèle pro ce modèle pro lgv en plus
c'est petit c'est le modèle standard
même si déjà très haut est vraiment au
top artistes qui est vraiment bien si
vous avez de la 20 h 30 et qui permettra
de recharger extrêmement rapidement en
une demi heure vous monte de 0 à 70 % de
charge sac est vraiment intéressant
c'est à dire que lorsque vous avez
oublié de recharger votre smartphone
vous ai plus beaucoup de batterie ou
fait patent vous allez vous avez une
bonne autonomie derrière et bien vous
prenez vous le branchez d'individus de
pouvoir repartir pendant un bon moment
vous êtes tranquille c'est très
rassurant je trouve ça bien c'est grave
charge 30 et elle est plus rapide que
celle qu'on avait déjà avec le one piece
est pro il ya quelques temps avec l'inde
en charge 30
là ils ont encore fait un pas
supplémentaire ça marche très bien c'est
très pratique le smartphone vous pouvez
garder jusqu'à deux jours autonomie ça
dépend bien évidemment de vos usages si
vous bourriner si vous y allez fortement
dessus il ya les deux jours vous ne les
aurais pas par contre sur un usage un
peu standard qui les deux jours vous les
avez l'idée avec le smartphone c'est que
vous ne pouviez plus la question de
recharger le soir vous posez plus la
question d'aller le brochet avant de
vous coucher pour l'avoir matin près si
vous avez oublié vous le branchez vous
repartez quand vous voulez vous êtes
tranquille attention quand même l'écran
90 enfin consommer davantage si vous
voulez consommer moins mais teymour 60
hertz
mais je vous dis une fois de plus vous
posez pas trop la question de ce point
de vue là parce que lorsque vous
rechargez et bien ça va très vite sur la
partie photo on a quasiment ce conte
avec le moins de plus cette épreuve
c'est à dire un capteur principal de 48
mégapixels salah sonia milk 586 qui va
voir la techno qu'alpiq ça leur donne un
petit plus de lui
1 lorsque vous êtes en conditions de
faible luminosité l'ouverture de f1
points si cela vous avez un tel objectif
de 12 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.2 qu'un
zoom optique x 2 et vous avez un ultra
grand-angle 16 mégapixels f 2.2 et qu'
un champ de vision de 120° vous invite à
lire mon test doit de plus cette tpr
haut il ya une petite différence
notamment au niveau du téléobjectif de
l'avoir en zoom optique x trop à la c1
jumeaux petit faut 2 sinon en terme de
rendu photo c'est quasiment la même
chose le traitement derrière avec
oxygène os marche bien et en plus vous
avez une nouveauté vous êtes en mode
macro
vous parlez de faire de la macro jusqu'à
2,5 cm ça marche bien je sais pas si
vous faites beaucoup de maquereaux je
sais pas s'il y aura beaucoup d' usage
derrière mais en tout cas si vous voulez
shooter tout d'un peu plus près et bien
vous pouvez le faire profil mais jusqu
en 4k à 60 images par seconde et
nautiques à la vente vous avez une
caméra de 16 mégapixels à une ouverture
de f 2.0
côté os je suis sur oxygen os 10 points
0 point 4 hd 65 des oeuvres comme ça
vous avez la complète qui tourne sur un
android disent personnellement j'aime
beaucoup ça vraiment bien ce que je
trouve intéressant sur oxygen ouais si
vous voulez c'est qu'il est très
fonctionnel il est très bien aboutie on
a accès très rapidement à tous les
paramètres on peut vraiment faire ce
qu'on veut j'aime beaucoup plus que
j'aime beaucoup
surman plus ces petits boutons que vous
avez là ça c'est pas une nouveauté on
l'avait déjà ses voûtes en mai m en mode
sonnerie en mode vibreur est en mode
silencieux vous de régler comme vous et
c'est très pratique en tout cas d'avoir
en boutons physiques de ce côté là en
dessous ces boutons pour venir à
l'allumer et pourrait être un tandis que
de l'autre côté vous allez retrouver le
bouton volume n'est pas le maître sont
très nombreux très complet nous sommes
au niveau de l'affichage tombe en tout
cas oxygène os c'est une des surcouches
que je préférais avec when you lie et en
plus de ça il ya un point qui est très
important c'est une voix ne plus te
promet des mises à jour pendant
plusieurs années au niveau de l'eau est
donc vous êtes trop cruel pouvoir
profiter des prochaines versions
d'android des prochaines versions
d'oxygène au s2 plus de sécurité
de nouvelles fonctionnalités pendant les
années à venir et ça croyez moi c'est
vraiment un gros plus le web plus
c'était donc un smartphone qui est
extrêmement aboutie bien réussie de la
part de one plus et je vous le dis le
flac thil qui leur à 599 euros
à moins de 600 euros vous avez ce qu'on
retrouve de mieux aujourd'hui un dragon
1855 plus ludique agréable en point le
dire on pourrait jusqu'à nous il
à ce moment là il faut aller sur le one
piece est des pros macready shot sitôt
suite beaucoup plus cher on n'est plus
dans la même gamme de prix on n'est plus
dans le côté flaccide keller le flagship
qui lors c'est définitivement celui là
le rôle de +7 et il est extrêmement bien
l'outil mais il n'est pas parfait dit
des choses que j'aurais souhaité
différentes notamment le fait de ne plus
avoir cette petite encoche goodall or ça
finira par disparaître dans les années à
venir pour l'instant tout cas fin 2019
sur ce modèle là c'est extrêmement
cohérent que one plus sur un modèle à
599 euros
vu la qualité de l'écran vue sont
capables de faire derrière ça nous met
une encoche c'est pas des cônes ans et
cohérent ça marche ça c'est plutôt bien
ce qui va également manquer par rapport
au modèle procès bien effectivement le
petit laser la petite caméra tough qui
nous permettra de faire un point plus
rapidement mais ça c'est des points de
détail se calcule en millisecondes
peut-être jusqu'à une seconde pour faire
le point mais franchement en termes
d'usagés vu une fois de plus le
positionnement tarifaire s'est pas
extrêmement grave
par contre le gros point positif c'est
ce smartphone il est fait pour tout le
monde
il est fait pour les gamers quelque
chose de très performante et aux quelque
chose qui va vite avec le ram boost avec
le mode fnatic avec le stand ragone 855
plus avec un excellent écran avec un
taux de rafraîchissement de 90 est
retombée c'est vraiment un smartphone
est destiné aux utilisateurs les plus
exigeants mais il est aussi destiné à
monsieur madame tout le monde qui
veulent du contenu multimédia de qualité
avec un écran horatio vingt neuvième
avec une très grosse définition avec une
belle qualité avec de l'audio immersif
avec du bluetooth 5.0 pour brancher un
casque directement dessus sans fuite ça
marche très bien vous allez pouvoir
utiliser aussi pour le crémant diamètre
organisé vous avez du nfc
si vous êtes un professionnel ou si vous
êtes frontaliers que vous avez deux
quartiers eh bien vous avez double
lecteur nano sim et une fois de plus
pandémie à tous qui est vraiment bien
c'est le retour haptique lorsque vous
allez je vous avais vraiment des
sensations qui vont vous immerger
davantage dans votre expérience de gym
pour les docks sur un smartphone
extrêmement aboutie le flagship qui leur
paraît excellence très complet pas
parfait mais quasiment un point de
détail près personnellement j'aurais
bien si vous voulez vraiment un
excellent smartphone fin 2019 un
excellent rapport qualité prix que ce
soit au niveau multimédia au niveau
photo au niveau performances au niveau
autonomie de quasiment tous les points
de vue et bien le one + 71 est vraiment
tout simplement excellent je vous invite
à venir vous maintenant ce que vous en
pensez en bas encore mentalement vous
trouvez sur une plus est est ce qu'il
vous plaît qu'est ce que vous pensez
go
allemand du boulot qui a été fait par
loin de plus cette année one + 7 ou à ne
plus être au deuxième semestre ou en
plus cette terre ou en plus cet éperon
one plus cette épreuve mclaren l'edition
avec le nom à rallonge
vous marquez tout ça en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on se retrouve
dès demain pour continuer à parler tu es
qui croyez moi il ya tellement de choses
à dire qu'on va recevoir pendant tout
moment nous embrasse à demain ciao